today on campaign check labour says it
will begin a wave of nationalizations in
the first 100 days of its term in office
the party's promised to bring rail mail
water energy and broadband all into
public ownership in its manifesto it
says the move will be fiscally mutual in
other words it won't cost the public
anything but it's that true let's take a
look at the figures first buying these
businesses will cost at least 50 billion
pounds that's the price of compensating
the current owners but these companies
also have existing debts of around 150
billion pounds but labour argues that's
all outweighed by the assets being added
to the government's balance sheet in
other words the value of the companies
it's acquiring estimated to also be
around 200 billion pounds so the numbers
add up right well in theory yes but
let's take a closer look first at that
50 billion figure the Shadow Chancellor
John McDonald has said labour wouldn't
sign a blank cheque for these businesses
the problem is that investors are
unlikely to be happy with just that 50
billion because it's what's known as The
Book value not the market value of the
businesses to take the water company
seventh rent as an example its Book
value in other words the physical value
of the assets like buildings and
infrastructure is around one point to
three billion but its market value which
takes into account things like future
profit is nearly five times that much at
more than five billion if Labour does
try and pay less than market value that
could pave way for legal action and it
could cost them dearly for example both
SSC and National Grid have set up
holding companies in jurisdictions like
Switzerland and Luxembourg where
treaties mean they'll have a better
chance in any potential future legal
action the real question though is
whether these businesses will be run
better in the public sector than they
were in the private sector if they make
big profits they'll be shared amongst
all of us but if they make losses the
taxpayer could be on the hook take the
rail industry as an example labour have
already pledged to cut rail fares by 33
percent at a
of about 1.5 billion pounds a cost that
wasn't in the labor manifesto and while
they say the money will be taken from a
road repair fund that will still mean
either 1.5 billion less gets spent on
roads or it needs to be raised in extra
taxes or borrowing so while it might be
possible to nationalize at no cost it's
by no means guaranteed and owning these
public utilities will expose the
taxpayer to potential risks as well as
potential game